[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels die
ferien sind schon da die sommerferien
lang ersehnt die kinder waren ja
eigentlich lange genug zu hause aber
egal sie haben den sommerferien und dann
kommt wieder die einstellung und wie
jedes jahr geht's natürlich auf einem
kanal eine einschulung torte die aus den
letzten jahren können wir euch natürlich
anschauen
ich habe jetzt besuch bekommen gestern
und erfreut ist der philipp man sieht
man das glaube ich schon wird da ist
philipp chor einkommen und der philipp
hat uns noch viele süßigkeiten
mitgebracht
hallo hallo und dann seien da nur auf
der terrasse
dann zeigt er mir diese fox weg zu den
nazis und ich meine wir zwei sind ja
kinder der noch nicht in den 90ern
geboren aber in den 90ern aufgewachsen
richtig und japan kommen wir können uns
eigentlich 90 geboren habe meinen dieses
jahr
ich bin 31 geworden und nicht gefordert
nächstes jahr will ich da 92 geworden
ist der 90 ja also ich weiß ja schon was
drin ist und wir haben die idee ich
mache eine einschulung torte es so eine
schultüte
ich habe schon mal eine schultüte macht
aber egal ich mache noch mal eine neue
und dann mache ich sofern die kenne ich
alles geil weil ganz in meiner schultüte
waren auch wieder süßigkeiten zu holen
und haben alles süßigkeiten und die
packen muss später reihen
die klassische artikel ja hallo wir
haben eine komplett immer okay und jetzt
hab ich die limited edition oder so was
ganz also wirklich besonderes nur dieses
jahr weil wir haben wir sagen jetzt
bubblegum gelernt was ebenfalls schon
gezeigt aber das ist nicht die 19 etwas
zu holen war ja spaß haben geschworen
ein genauer als kaubonbon deshalb gibt
es eine limited edition box
dann hab ich die mitgebracht ach nein
wir feiern die 90er jahre weiter und das
am liebsten mit dir zusammen und das
ganze auf den titel work nein wie co
location pavillon eine wand zu malen was
macht dann heute abend mein gott ich
hatte noch nie eine bauchtasche ein ganz
richtig früher hat man sich doch dann
taucht jetzt aber ohne das war so und
jetzt trägt man sie so natürlich trägt
sie das wie immer so auch mein kurz
angebunden checken
ach wie cool dass das mache ich mir
gleich drauf die ganze family jamaal
später
ich zocke ich muss ihn abzufangen
ach nein die musste man sich dann so
wartete so passt es ganz gut
und dann so richtig so cindy lauper
möglich im jahre so so richtig so ein
hund pferdeschwanz wippt sitzt so konnte
jetzt sehr wichtig da haben wir gleich
den mentees party
ich kannte es ist für den arm noch
scheinen dann sitzt man mal überlegt
mega okay jetzt muss ich aber noch ein
lippenstift kann demnach das spiel okay
[Musik]
wir sind die kinder in der neuen liga
entwickelt lesen
das ist ja also das schild ist im
strumpfhosen ausprobiert auch noch an zu
packen
dank wir sehen uns später und das
leckere immer zusammen das machbar
los gehts also mit der torte ich hab mir
gedacht ich mache jetzt einfach einen
blechkuchen und da habe ich das
grundrezept von meinem blog und in der
app genommen und zwar den mandeln
rührkuchen habe dafür die eier mit dem
zucker salz und vanille extrakte richtig
schön schaumig gerührt dann kommt etwas
butter milch mit öl dazu dann gemahlenen
mandeln mit mehl und backpulver und
fertig ist schon gerührt kuchen da wird
dann direkt in den bug rahmen ein
gegossen und dann eben im ofen gebacken
den kuchen habe ich jetzt hier bereits
raus geholt also die ganz ausführlich im
schritte könnt ihr euch gerne im
grundrezept anschauen
der kuchen ist auch schon schön
abgekühlt ich stelle ihn jetzt aber
schon weil er abgekühlt ist noch in den
kühlschrank oder ins gefrierfach
so ist es sich gleich besser schneiden
und ich hab mir gedacht ich probiere
heute mal was neues aus und zwar eine
buttercreme zum anrühren
da gebe ich nämlich nur wasser und
butter dazu falls in die buttercreme
selber machen wollt könnt ihr zum
beispiel die italienische oder die swiss
waren peter grimm machen gibt es auch
schon rezepte auf einem kanal
grundrezepte ihr könnt die torte aber
auch mit ghanas fühlen dass eine creme
aus schokolade und sahne da gibt es auch
schon ein grundrezept also entscheidet
einfach selbst ort erfüllen möchte
ich mache das so und bei der buttercreme
es
so nehme ich den beutel inhalt und
verrühren mit wasser ich mache jetzt mal
die doppelte menge weil ich noch nicht
so genau weiß wie groß die torte wird
aber ich schreibe euch dann in den blog
natürlich und ins konzept
die füllmenge ich gebraucht habe aber
lieber habe ich ein bisschen zu viel als
zu wenig die mutter habe ich bereits
zimmer waren die brauche ich aber erst
später und kann jetzt hier alles mit
wasser verrühren nichts nach vanille
[Musik]
kurz glatt rühren
jetzt denke ich es ab und lass es 30
minuten stehen und frühere danach
einfach noch die weiche butter in
wisconsin
weiter geht's mit der buttercreme also
wie gesagt ich probierte zuerst einmal
ich beziehe die weiche butter lebt da
das dazu und dann wird das ganze für
zehn minuten schaumig gerührt oder
cremig gerührt bis es eine tolle
konsistenz hat und ich nehme den
schneebesen aufsatz weil die butter
wirklich schon schön weich ist
[Musik]
die buttercreme ist fertig hier habe ich
den kuchen der schon abgekühlt und jetzt
ist mir eingefallen inspiriert von der
neuen xbox mache ich jetzt folgendes ich
nehme es die hippies die bubble gum die
werte ich als füllung noch einmal nicht
nur dekor sondern okay das heißt die hab
ich jetzt ein bisschen ich glaube das
wird cool weil dann habe ich diesen
bubblegum geschmack nämlich in der tat
so
[Musik]
aber jetzt geht's erst einmal an die
torte aus dieser eckigen platte mache
ich jetzt eine schuld hätte das fragt
sich noch wie aber ich mache das jetzt
erstmal so drittel der jetzt einfach
manchmal habe ich vorher noch keinen
plan und dann gibt's einfach dann kann
es hier für die buttercreme die lasse
ich jetzt auch so geschmack da kommen
jetzt die hippies drauf
[Musik]
dann hier die platte drauf und dann
hardheim
[Musik]
für jungen ist schon mal fertig jetzt
der deckel drauf und jetzt darf die
torte erstmal in die kühlung hier noch
ein bisschen glatt streichen denn ich
schneide da gleich die schultüte zu die
creme stelle ich auch kurz in den
kühlschrank weil sie in der küche sehr
warm ist und dann kann ich in der
zwischenzeit aber schon mal ein bisschen
deko vorbereiten denn die schultüte die
braucht auch dekoration die knete ich
jetzt einfach ein paar farben von santa
rosa da brauche ich nix rein mission
lila und weiß für mich ein bisschen für
ein helleres lila grün und weiß für mich
und dann brauche ich einfach noch gelb
und hellblau
[Musik]
da bist ein echter die richtigen farben
für so einen ein tief torte gleich den
fondant mit becker stärker ausrollen
ich brauche eigentlich echt immer nur so
ein bisschen ganz dünn ausrollen und es
geht mit dem auch recht gut da ist
nämlich shea butter drin statt palmfett
also wirklich hochwertiges fett und
dadurch ist er von dante elastischer und
reist nicht so schnell
ich will jetzt erstmal alle so ein
bisschen aus und was ich dann nicht
brauche verpacke ich gleich luftdicht
damit eben nicht trocknet ihr könnt ihr
jetzt wenn ihr sagt ich möchte eine
andere schuldtitel machen keine neuen
tiefs sondern aus diesem jahrhundert und
aus der jetzigen zeit dann gestaltet sie
etwas so wie ihr möchtet
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir noch so typische muster
zum einen natürlich kreise und da machen
das jetzt auch so schaut man sich
nämlich einfach so eine spritztour ich
auf eine größere und kleinere und dann
kann man daraus nämlich geringe
auszustechen entstand das gleiche noch
mal mit einer anderen frage und so wird
es dann später so dieses coole musste
und dann mache ich noch ein paar
dreiecke und vierecke und dann anders
logisch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so sieht's gut aus
jetzt habe ich hier eine schablone guck
mal wie ich jetzt am besten die torte
schneide ich glaube ich mache das so
einfach so den einfachsten winkel nehmen
und dann hier am setzen und so schneiden
da guck dir einfach wie groß eure trotte
sein soll
und hier vorne diesem beutel den
schneide ich jetzt somit also diese
runde perfekt
das nehme ich ein bisschen von der
buttercreme geklebt die torte herrn und
damit die torte ihr könnt sie entweder
so lassen oder schon ein bisschen 3d
machen und ich finde es immer schön wenn
sie wirklich 3d wird wenn auch nur
leicht und ich finde von der größe her
ist sie jetzt wirklich super so dass ich
sagen muss nicht so viel nicht zu wenig
um die reste könnt ihr dann noch nehmen
sind hier oben noch besser aufbauen das
einfach eine schöne rundungen bekommt
da müsst ihr euch einfach so ein bisserl
nach gefühl vorantasten und immer wieder
creme nehmen messer ansetzen bisschen
was wegschneiden und hier unten auch so
ein bisschen unter den boden schneiden
damit die rundung schon noch ein
bisschen weiter geht
ich glaube so langsam die einfache menge
an buttercreme hat doch gereicht aber
wird wollte lieber ein bisserl zu viel
da haben wobei ich bin ja auch blöd weil
ich meine man kann dir einfach ganz
schnell anrühren naja egal
deswegen teste ich sage euch vor und
könnte danach machen
mit den richtigen mengen verhältnissen
jetzt schön einstreichen mit der
kompletten creme die nämlich auch von
dann tauglich das ist perfekt das heißt
wenn man echt mal ganz schnell so ein
motiv torte machen will
buttercreme kurz umrühren nach belieben
auch geschmacklich verfeinert mit sirup
mit aromen mit zitronenschale vanille
wobei wahrlich schmeckt sie schon also
richtig gut einfärben und dann geht s
baku und dekorieren echt rucki zucki
schnell
ich streiche jetzt hier schon ein stellt
sie wieder ins gefrierfach damit sie
fest wird und dann kommt noch mal so
topp coating drauf also wirklich nochmal
für die letzte schöne glatte schicht und
dann geht's schon an die decke
[Musik]
jetzt kurz kühlen und dann wie gesagt
noch mal schön glatt streichen aber so
geht es ruckzuck und ganz schnell und
vor allem ist ganz gut denn man hat zum
stückchen zum direkt menschen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier hellblau fondant
damit über sich jetzt die torte also
wird die schultüte bei mir helfen
[Musik]
und dann schön glatt streichen
doch so eine schöne größe also für so
eine kleine feine die familienfeier zur
einschulung passt die porsche perfekt
die reste hier außen wegschneiden und so
ein bisschen drunter schieben also ein
bisschen das ganze dreidimensionaler
[Musik]
spitze einfach weggeschnitten vom stoff
vorne kann ich den überrest auch
wegschneiden denn da kommt ja auf die
andere farbe hin
[Musik]
und da nehme ich jetzt einfach die
rückseite da passt die torte perfekt
drauf und da lege ich jetzt die masse
drauf und das ist dann die tafel und da
legt man die schuldtitel drauf ja so
mache ich das
dann auf den ausbau starb aufrollen
nehme ich meinen tablett ja sei alles
essbare von daher ich gebe dir halt s
bahn kleber drauf und das kann man
später alles wieder weggewaschen und
jetzt aber das ist gar nicht schlimm
denn der von land ist ja elastisch ich
habe jetzt hier so eine rand und kann
mich da entlang hangeln und einfach
schön glatt wegschneiden
schon eine tafel liebe schulen wenn ihr
keine tafel mal habt euch eine da kommt
jetzt darauf jetzt wirklich oben schön
platz lassen damit die ganzen
süßigkeiten das platz haben und jetzt
lebe ich hier die ganze decke drauf die
namen habe ich jetzt noch ausgestochen
und die deko einfach mit essbarem kleber
aufkleben
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt ein bisschen grün
fondant mit blüten pasta gemischt
fondant an sich hätte jetzt nicht so aus
dass er bleibt immer schön auf der
torten oberfläche weich für den
anschnitt und blüten passte daraus kann
man ganz filigrane sachen formen und die
härtet wirklich gut aus wenn man beides
eins zu eins mischt hat man den
modelliermasse die gut aushärtet und die
eben auch schön in form bleibt und damit
mache ich jetzt gleich dieses
krepppapier denn zu unserer zeit waren
die schultüten oben mit krepppapier oder
auch mit stoff sogar schön dünn und ich
möchte dieses krepppapier jetzt noch ein
bisschen strukturieren und ihr kennt ja
vielleicht schon diese stempel diese
prägestempel die könnt ihr zum beispiel
benutzen bei seiner stein optik die wir
einfach für die harry potter torte
perfekt gewesen
ich hab mal so ein korbgeflecht und hier
noch so andere muster mit dem mini
erzielen mit zu kleinen kreuzchen und
die nehme ich jetzt und drückt es hier
einfach vorsichtig rein
august sieht cool aus guckt immer gut
dann hole ich doch jetzt mal die torte
und wird der koreaner gehört also kurze
frage und zwei drittel zum ja saure
spinnenbeine okay ja total coolen
artikel machen echt spaß und schon sauer
und dann auch ein richtig cooler artikel
aber der name volles rohr
der passt nicht so ganz jetzt ist die
frage an euch wie nennen wir den artikel
also das ist praktisch sauer und innen
drin sind von dort sah ich vanille teig
jetzt müssen uns da irgendeinen namen
überlegen wie wir die das sind die
lakers und ich nehme aber dann also da
muss man auch mal die drachen volles
rohr ist da noch nicht da kommt lasst
doch community fragen oder machen an
gewinnspiel 3 ja aber gute fußballer
wir schauen in die kommentare und wer
kommentar abgibt mit dem coolsten namen
der dann ausgesucht wird von philipp der
branche box also seid kreativ viel spaß
jetzt wo sie an der deko ok koma ich hab
das gedacht ist jetzt die tafel ich habe
hier weiße lebensmittelfarbe verdünnt
und schreibe jetzt erstmal auf die tafel
so zur einschulung von 113 ebenso zu
einstellungen so einfach das alles ist
da machen wir nochmal die erste klasse
schon aus wie trafen
[Musik]
wie machen wir das jetzt also eigentlich
wollen also eine geschlossene schultüte
sieht glaube ich cool aus aber ich
glaube auch sieht noch cooler master
bundesrat machen aber ich müsste die
torte kurz anheben sollte unkonzentriert
und orten dienstag
hier kannst du damit unterschieden
[Musik]
als ich jetzt sagen wir packen jetzt
hier die ganzen süßigkeiten rainer
eigentlich ist der geschlossene studio
ganz schön aber wir lassen sie offen
aber eine info habe ich jetzt noch die
glaube ich ganz wichtig ist uns weise
oft immer das problem dass man in
produkten schweine certina hat ja dann
nehmen es viele nicht vegan an ich muss
eben nicht egal wäre und dann habt ihr
ja gerade die hit lösungen die löwen ihr
habt ja martin amis winterquartiere und
diese war lange nicht klar es ist
vielleicht so steht es auch drauf halten
leider hat oder murat gastein guten tipp
beschreiben darauf hinarbeiten ganze
arabische kennt nicht ganz parabel als
courage nachlesen aber das hätte ich
jetzt nicht lese ich dich und jordi alba
drauf und das habt ihr aber auch einige
genau vegane und jünger haben alle
saftige sind alle gegangen also sogar
genau und schließe die wahl ist noch
unklar
gewinn war zogen aber ja mein klassiker
aus dem 1
ich mag die blauen ja okay was ist los
geht's rein ich hier müssen jetzt
bisschen volumen schaffen
[Musik]
jetzt natürlich ist doch hammer oder so
hirt und schön ja coole idee das hier ja
super schön dann kann man's ja ich muss
jetzt nur noch richtig einstimmen
megaschön das war super schön
so war unsere erste schultern
[Musik]
hört sich gut an wieder das ist meine
schultüte haben wir probieren
los geht's haye ist ein stück weg
gespannt hersteller hippies erwünscht
aber es kommt dieser bubblegum flavour
durch
und dann dieser vanille oder die creme
das ist echt cool ich muss das noch mal
machen
nicht im bild haben geschmack ich muss
noch einmal mit einem sauren hätten
da ich auch richtig cool war echt cool
becker nun vereinfacht die torte gar
nicht geplant
aber egal es witzig ich habe nicht so
hübsch benutzt also so klein
das war fragen die lagen da und dann das
mega lag aber es gibt dem kuchen noch so
ein bisschen irgendwie mal kuchen geht
ja sonst immer so gemeistert auto genau
ist und die bleiben halt echt schön
clark und es passt total zu buchen ist
richtig coole idee ja also probieren
probiert's aus denkt anders gewünscht
mehr
er könnte ganz viele bilder mit diesem
hause wenn ihr genau zehn prozent
firmenanteile aber mit beim gewinnspiel
kommentiert wir sind gespannt erfolg ja
auch gut gemacht ist einfach zuschauer
entscheiden wer den namen
ich meine die sind die fans da draußen
[Musik]
so
wir geben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
velen git